now the january 6 investigation and what
happened to those secret service text
messages the national archive wants to
know how the service lost messages
linked to the assault on the capitol and
the secret service has confirmed just
yesterday in fact that the messages
cannot be recovered it says they
disappeared during a long scheduled
service update back in 2021.
scott mcfarlane is on capitol hill for
us once again where the january 6 select
committee is preparing for tomorrow
night's prime time hearing
scott good morning
tony good morning to you there will be
some key witnesses at that hearing
tomorrow witnesses who worked inside the
trump white house on january 6. but it's
the search for those missing text
messages that has so many people here
searching for answers
tuesday's deadline for the secret
service came and went some of the text
messages exchanged within the agency on
january 5th and 6th 2021 remain missing
not handed over despite a subpoena from
the january 6th select committee
potentially deleted and irretrievable
well one thing i've learned in this
process is that when one evidentiary
door closes another one will open and
we'll find a way the national archives
has ordered an internal review of what
it calls unauthorized deletion of text
by the secret service which this morning
is pledging full cooperation the january
6 committee have been seeking the
records ahead of thursday's prime time
hearing which the panel says will show
dereliction of duty by former president
trump during the riot despite urgent
warnings from his inner circle
two white house aides who quit after the
attack former deputy national security
adviser matt pottinger and deputy press
secretary sarah matthews will be the
star witnesses and john wood a former
lead investigator on the january 6
committee told cbs news the panel will
show trump's inaction that day i think
they need to finish by focusing on those
critical 187 minutes between when the
attack on the capitol started and when
donald trump finally issued a video
statement asking people to leave the
capital meanwhile this morning the
justice department presents a second day
of witnesses in the contempt of congress
trial of former trump strategist steve
bannon who's criminally charged with
stonewalling this committee tuesday a
committee aide testified the panel
subpoena wasn't optional had a clear
deadline and that bannon's testimony was
needed after sitting silent with a mask
much of the day bannon uncorked his
criticism for the committee members
outside have the guts and the courage
the guts and the courage to show up here
and say exactly why it's a crime
committee members tell us we'll hear
more tomorrow from that pre-taped
deposition it did with former trump
white house counsel pat sipoloni but one
familiar face will likely be missing
tomorrow committee chairman benny
thompson of mississippi says he's tested
positive for covid that the hearings
will proceed even in his absence tony
got it scott thank you very much